parmi la quarantaine de chefs d'état et
de gouvernement rassemblés dans la
tribune le président syrien bachar al
assad dont la présence a suscité
quelques grincements de dents la syrie
avait été indirectement mis en cause
dans l'assassinât de l'ambassadeur de
france au liban en 80 et dans la tente
en 83 contre un bâtiment de l'armée
française de drakkars où avaient péri 58
militaires rappel des faits avec
philippe rochot et thomas donzel
quand nicolas sarkozy arrive à la
tribune d'honneur il peut voir que
rarement 14 juillet aura réuni autant de
chefs d'état une quarantaine pour
assister au défilé avec un personnage
clé pour la paix au proche-orient bachar
el-assad qui va se trouvait à quelques
mètres du premier ministre israélien
ehud olmert
même angela merkel approuvent à présent
ce sommet de l'union pour la
méditerranée qui s'est terminée hier et
a permis à ses dirigeants souvent en
conflit de se retrouver sous un même
toit n'est pas forcément du goût de tout
le monde
l'étiquette de dictature colle encore à
la peau du régime syrien s'est pas c'est
pas le droit de le roi des droits de
l'homme
maintenant aux états unis il ne serait
pas le bienvenu mais c'est la différence
avec la politique de votre président
des militants de reporters sans
frontières qui demandait la liberté en
syrie ont été interpellés c'était
légitime d'être là pour le 14 juillet
alors qu'on reçoit de ce match r la sat
qui est un dictateur à la place de de
célébrer les valeurs de la révolution
française par la prise de la bastille
quoi c'est à dire la chute de
l'autoritarisme bachar el assad sait
qu'il n'est pas forcément le bienvenu
il va donc renoncer à la garden party de
l'elysée et se contentera d'un déjeuner
à l'hôtel marigny avec son épouse
je suis déjà venue en france il y à 29
ans j'étais étudiant apprécier ou non
bachar el assad sait qu'il faut compter
avec lui et il attend beaucoup des
élections américaines
j'ai beaucoup plus d'espoir dans la
future administration américaine que
dans celle ci
quand on parle de paix c'est un
processus qui ne commencera que dans six
mois avec le prochain gouvernement
américain il faudra donc du temps à voir
la signature d'un traité de paix israélo
syrien nicolas sarkozy le sait le
conflit du proche-orient en restera un
frein à l'union pour la méditerranée